this is excuse me damn fine cup of
coffee let's face it we're hooked on the
stuff most of us can't even start our
day without a nice cup of joe according
to the International coffee organization
over 1 billion cups of coffee are
consumed every day so it's safe to say
as a whole
we're big time Catholics but what would
happen if you stopped drinking coffee
and what would happen to our society if
we took away this energizing brew this
is what if and here's what would happen
if everyone stopped drinking coffee
coffee goes hand in hand with caffeine
caffeine is a pro at mimicking a
neurotransmitter called adenosine
adenosine slows down nerve impulses in
the brain causing drowsiness as it
depresses the central nervous system in
the process
in other words it makes you feel relaxed
caffeine on the other hand is kind of a
Trojan horse it's molecules bind to
these adenosine receptors and block them
increasing your dopamine levels and
making you more alert it's a stimulant
drug helping the brain get messages to
the body quicker in general caffeine is
not the worst thing in the world for a
person in moderation and that's the key
word here it has some pros but there's
also a risk of developing a caffeine
dependency that can result in some
serious health issues so what would
happen to you if you stopped drinking
coffee well if you did you'd want to
wean yourself off of the stuff if it
disappeared this instant you'd be a
little bit more than grumpy it's almost
guaranteed that you'd feel some
withdrawal effects you could expect to
have headaches fatigue and insomnia
not to mention nasty bouts of
constipation depression and anxiety but
if we were all on board could we benefit
from taking coffee out of our morning
rituals well in the long run
technically we would be a lot healthier
but that doesn't mean we'd be in the
clear without coffee in our day we'd be
eliminating the biggest source of
caffeine for the majority of Earth's
population people would just find other
ways to get there fix the energy drink
market could see a spike in sales and
that could be dangerous
to name just one example the World
Health Organization is officially on
record as saying that the health risks
associated with energy drinks are mainly
due to their caffeine levels some of the
effects include heart palpitations
nausea convulsions and vomiting yeesh
there would also be another cost if
everyone stopped drinking coffee a
literal one what would happen to our
society well the top commodity in the
world is oil but do you know what's
right behind it in second place
that's right coffee coffee is grown in
more than 50 countries and 25 million
farmers around the world rely on coffee
crops to make a living in the United
States alone the coffee industry is
worth 225 billion dollars and has
created nearly 1.7 million jobs sadly
this is a case where economics is going
to win out over the well-being of humans
if coffee simply disappeared overnight
no questions asked we'd be looking at
the collapse of a multi-billion dollar
industry and what do you think do you
think everyone could really stop
drinking coffee
well it's doable to an extent if you
decide to quit drinking coffee there are
caffeine free alternatives such as
chicory coffee which is made from
chicory root if you still want to drink
something with caffeine in it like black
tea be aware of the dangers like alcohol
caffeine is a socially acceptable
substance that can lead to some issues
and while rare in extreme cases too much
caffeine can kill you it's safe to say
that coffee drinkers are not in a rush
to take coffee out of their lives but
think of the other stuff we put in our
morning cup
what would happen if there was no sugar
in the world well that's a story for
another what is
[Applause]
you